we don't have any pro-lifers here right
we don't have any pro we're right now
we're talking about men's rights
okay okay okay so so what's your name
all right Ariana I'm Pearl nice to meet
you nice to meet you rainbow nice to
meet you nice to meet you if a woman has
a choice of whether or not she's wants
to be a mother right should a man have
the choice of whether or not she he
wants to be a father in the name of
equality yeah
yeah
I mean
everyone has their own choices of what
they want to do with their life so I
mean if a woman has
their own choice of whether they want to
be a mother or not I guess obviously if
the dad doesn't want to be in the life
of their child then that's up to them
what do you think I'm looking confused I
thought we were talking about pro-life
approach voices no so so what we're
talking about so if I if I want to get
an abortion in the UK right I can get an
abortion up to six months but if a man
says I don't want to be a father he's
still on the hook for child support and
depending on how many kids there are
it's between 13 and 20 percent so that
incentivizes women to get kids off of
Rich guys for example in the U.S the NBA
players had a statement being issued out
that
um to flush their condoms because girls
were stealing them and so if we get the
right not to be mothers like shouldn't
they get the right not to be fathers so
they could sign off all their rights and
sign off on child support they don't owe
anything
I mean if the father doesn't want to be
in the child's life then like and they I
don't think the child would deserve that
then yeah it has bad effects on the
child on the child essentially because
that causes like psychological harm and
stuff
but at the end of the day I mean it is
up to the the father but at the end of
the day like the child's life
if the child's brought into the world
like your child's life kind of matters
and whether your child is going to be a
happy child or not or disrupted child
that's kind of up to whether you have
one
um
one kind of parent parental figure in
their life and or two yeah and I'm not
saying he shouldn't be in the LA in
their life I'm just saying in the name
of equality it should be even so like he
shouldn't owe child support but I think
we agree then
like he shouldn't be on the hook for
child support because the guy can go to
jail for not paying child support
um
they can they can Seize Your they can
seize your assets
I didn't know I didn't know that that's
just a bit
I didn't know that that's quite shocking
that's
I don't know that's yeah but it seems
like we're all on the same page you'd be
okay with a financial abortion format
I wouldn't want like if I don't want my
I want my father's what my child's
father to like if he doesn't want to be
in the Father's Love didn't deserve
whether they meant to pay I wouldn't
want them to pay then at that point you
know yeah if he doesn't want to be that
I don't want him to like be forced to
kind of pay for everything to do with
the child however like me having that
experience of like growing up with two
parents and stuff it's definitely been a
lot better than people that I know that
have grown up like without a father and
without a mother like it's a lot
different for them do you think it's
better if people are married before they
have kids oh
[__] happens yeah stuff I mean Some
people prefer to be in like a very
committed like lockdown relationship
before they have children but I mean
there's a lot of people that aren't
married but have kids what do you think
what was the question again do you think
people it's better for the chill the
children If the parents are married
before they have them
no I mean I don't
I don't see the
impact of like because there's a lot of
people like my parents weren't married
before they had all their kids and they
only got married
probably before their last two kids and
had about five before that and all of us
have turned out fine all of us have you
know stayed like that and whatever
there's a lot of kids out there that
their parents aren't married per se and
I don't think that has an impact on you
think it's more important just to have
both parents in the home yeah well to
have both parents there it's more
obviously I believe I ideally I think
just in the times that we are in now
you can still
you can still yeah
so raise a child you don't need
obviously it's ideal and everyone wants
it's harder obviously yeah but I don't
think that
like you can still do it it's still
possible you've seen there's so many
people who have like raised their child
as a single parent and they've turned
out fine yeah and they're strong and
they're all the qualities you want in a
child statistically your kids more at
risk if you at like every statistical
Advantage disadvantage obviously yeah
but like it's life I mean everything you
won't get everything you won't always
get the marriage the dream marriage you
won't always sometimes you have a kid
before marriage and if so what happens
you try your best and yeah obviously
statistically yeah you'd better have two
parents and two figures in the house in
the home but do you think once you get
married it's about the kids happiness
and not yours
I think that should be a balance
obviously you put your kids before
yourself
but
I think even before you're married like
and you have kids before you're married
you essentially put all your energy and
stuff into your child and making your
child happy and like having the best
life for your child but there has to be
a balance between your happiness to take
care of yourself yes your personal
happiness and you know your side of life
as well as your child's side of life
there has to be that balance but yeah
essentially like having two parents
there and having one parent there I
think nowadays you know it's not really
too big of a deal having a single parent
but then like obviously back in the day
like years and years ago like when our
parents were younger it would always be
seen as like the two parents it was seen
as like you have to have two parents
with your child it's better for your
children blah blah obviously it's better
but like
it's more ideal to have two parents
rather than one because
yeah that's but I mean that that's like
stereotypical of like it's better more
ideal to have two parents but nowadays
it's like you can raise a child by
yourself and be a single parent like
I've seen it low we're doing public
interviews no okay hi hi public
interviews hi
you want to be interviewed we asked the
public in London their opinion on
certain topics
hi what's your name
Ellie
do you have any social media you want to
plug no no it's fine yeah so today's
topic her body her choice right
do you sense women have the right not to
be mothers if they don't want to should
men have the right not to be fathers if
they don't want to
yes in in
um
I'm not sure how her body her choice
um what's the connection here because
that's about abortion well let's leave
that aside women have the right to give
up the child for adoption yes yes and
yes that is mentioned absolutely at the
same right to give up the child for
adoption
um because that would be really like for
like we talk about the rights I don't
think to draw parallel between abortion
and and men not being fathers but
certainly if you're talking about giving
up the child to adoption or disavowing
yeah then men should have the same right
as women and women do have that right
why don't you think it's comparable
abortion and
um child support abortion is a different
question
um
it's whether the woman has the right to
abort the child or not I mean even if
you might you might agree that a woman
has the right not to have to physically
support
um with her body I mean physically
obviously everything would do is
physically but I mean you might agree
the woman doesn't need to physically
um give life to the child and yet you
would still think that the woman should
have to feed a child if the child is
born and vice versa he could think that
the woman shouldn't be able to kill the
child because it's it's a human being
and yet you could still support the
right of the woman or the man to give
her the childhood option said I don't
think he can I mean he can he can be on
one side of one argument on the other
side the other arguments basically are
you are you pro-life
um yes that's I'd say broadly speaking
yes do you think it should be illegal
all of the time
um probably the best argument could be
made for